good morning John and good morning Alice
and welcome to earth it's a wonderful
terrible place and you are a member of
its most wonderful and terrible species
and you're being born into what may be
the most interesting time in human
history if all goes well within your
lifetime humans will walk on Mars
computers will become intelligent the
paralyzed will walk again absolute
poverty will be all but eliminated and
you Alice may very well live to be over
a hundred years of age or maybe this
advanced peculiar unique institution of
human technological society will implode
taking all humans and a good piece of
the earth with it go either way really
in any case both you and I will be a
part of that future but luckily you
don't really have to worry about any of
that right now because you're a baby you
just have to worry about being a baby
but nobody ever said being a baby was
easy and so are your uncle Hank I've
created a simple guide to how to be a
baby in six easy steps one you are stuck
out here so get used to it you probably
don't know this because you're a human
baby but human babies are born pretty
premature when compared to other
placental mammals because our heads have
evolved to be super big and they're hard
to get out of the mom after a certain
point in development so you're basically
still an embryo which is really
unpleasant to be outside of the mother
at that point so it's gonna suck you're
gonna want to be swaddled and warm and
you want to what whooshing noises and
stuff like that and I suggest you just
cry until that stuff happens speaking of
crying you will discover that making the
really terrible noise is actually very
easy for you it's basically just like
making any other noise but you gotta
want to look like it's really difficult
like squint you face up get it all red
and puffy and cry your vocal cords right
now are designed to tap directly into
your parents sympathy centers so that's
gonna be a useful tool for you three I
would suggest that you do a lot of
sleeping but not in like normal human
ways you're gonna want to sleep for
about two and a half hours at a time
that way your parents will approach but
never quite achieve REM sleep which is
going to be hilarious when they start
having hallucinations for put stuff in
your mouth turns out because we are so
underdeveloped as newborn babies your
nervous system is really terrible so far
complicated sensing is really only right
around here so if you want to know what
something is you just call oh oh
low-five communication is the key to any
effective relationship you'll really
only have two ways to communicate right
now one is the crying which we've
discussed previously lying is something
you want to do just whenever pretty much
all the time doesn't matter really how
you're feeling hungry sleepy thirsty you
don't like that smell your butt feels
weird you just bored crying just cry in
all of those situations but number six
do you have another communicative tool
one that you want to be more sparing
with because it is extremely powerful
and that is your cuteness be careful
with your cute it is extremely potent
your cute is not just about inspiring
love and devotion getting pinches on the
cheeks and people saying you're cute is
the key to our hope our ability to see
beyond our own lifespan to feel as if we
are part of a continuum that stretches
back to the first self-replicating
life-forms you're cute reminds us that
the decisions we make now will someday
affect you and your children and your
children's children that you are the
next step and hopefully a better step in
this wonderful terrible process that we
call humanity I hope that's not too much
pressure Alice I wish I could see you
right now and hold you and go over your
belly on I also wish I could see you but
I won't for a little while but Craig I
will see you on Tuesday